So I'm going to shift us all backwards a little bit to talk about allogeneic transplant again
with focus on AML and specifically looking at the use of maintenance therapy.
Now, as we all probably know by now, there's really substantial evidence for giving FLT3
tyrosine kinase inhibitors, or TKIs, as maintenance therapy post-transplant.
And this data is actually probably best for serafinib, where we have two large randomized
phase 3 studies, the SOAR main study with 83 patients and the Chinese study with 202
patients, both of which showed a significant reduction in relapse at two and one years
respectively with respect to placebo.
Moving sort of clockwise around this slide, we also have the MORFO study, which most people
here are probably very familiar with, of giltaritinib versus maintenance.
And while this didn't actually show a significantly significant reduction in relapse with a p-value
of 0.0518.
I think we all audibly sighed when we saw that.
There were differences among pre-specified subsets, such as MRD positivity.
And then finally, in RADIUS, which looked at mitostaurin maintenance, there was a numerical
reduction in relapse, even if that wasn't significant.
Now, there are a lot of caveats to these studies, and I could probably give in a separate talk
altogether, just talking about the problems with the way these were designed or some nuances.
But suffice it to say, this is enough data to convince the NCCN that all patients with
FLT3 FLT3-positive AML undergoing transplant should be at least considered for some sort
of maintenance therapy.
However, as I mentioned before, there's a lot of nuances to these studies.
Patients on these trials were younger and fitter.
The median age was actually 35 to 54.
Many patients were TKI-naive, had never seen a FLT3 inhibitor prior to maintenance, and
many trials restricted to patients in CR1.
Obviously, patients in the real world are different.
Our patients are older.
They have more comorbidities.
Pillow burden and polypharmacy are real considerations.
As is tolerability.
Even in these sort of idealized clinical trial situations, 22 to 59% of patients either had
to stop maintenance therapy altogether or reduce dose because they couldn't tolerate
the side effects.
And remember, these are patients who, in theory, are cured of these diseases.
Because of that, I wanted to look at the use of maintenance with a special focus on
tolerability in the real world and did this using administrative clients.
I'm going to talk about the use of maintenance in the real world and the use of the use of
claims data.
I specifically looked at two outcomes at interest.
The first is adherence.
And you can think of this as, were there any gaps in prescribing?
How many potential days in which a patient could be on maintenance were covered by a
prescription?
Based on the solid tumor literature for oral oncology drugs, perfect adherence is considered
at least 80% of potential days are covered by a prescription for a drug.
Next, I looked at persistence, or how long do patients stay on therapy?
And again, borrowing from the previous slide, I looked at the use of maintenance in the
real world.
And I looked at the use of maintenance in the real world.
Based on the solid tumor literature for oral oncology drugs, perfect adherence is considered
at least 80% of potential days are covered by a prescription for a drug.
And again, borrowing from the previous slide, I looked at the use of maintenance in the
real world.
And again, borrowing from the previous slide, I looked at the use of maintenance in the real
world.
And again, borrowing from the previous slide, I looked at the use of maintenance in the
real world.
And again, borrowing from the previous slide, I looked at the use of maintenance in the real
world.
And again, borrowing from the previous slide, I looked at the use of maintenance in the
real world.
And again, borrowing from the previous slide, I looked at the use of maintenance in the real
world.